hervé this bonjour merci nous recevoir à
nouveau à l'agroparistech de paille
affiliés toujours aux leurs on croit
déjà ou s'entraînera que joseph est
passé près d'une nuée mer entre l'agro
paris tech et l'inra n'est qu'un vieux
maire veut dire unité mixte de recherche
voilà donc là aujourd'hui nous sommes
partis pour de nouvelles découvertes à
savoir enfants enfin connaître la
cuisine note à note
et ben on attend beaucoup de choses de
vous on a bien nous expliquer tout ça
que ce soit bien bien clair d'abord
comment comment c'est venu au tout début
aux sedin et c'est venu avec qu'opposer
voilà c'est venu dans les années 90 je
suis un peu gourmand et donc mais une
gourmandise qui est tourné vers les
autres dire que je moi j'aime bien des
copains à des résines et lançait à
manger il faut faire la cuisine devant
mais je enfin jeu ça c'est ma vie
normale on va dire et la vie
professionnelle c'est quand même de
connaître ce genre de d'objets ça c'est
des produits tels qu'on aille dans les
soutes de chimie et celui là par exemple
qui s'appelle le 1 oct m3 hall d'accord
donc c'est certain
soyez sérieux c'est une sorte de liquide
qui est transparent
ils ressemblent à de l'eau mais c'est
pas de l'eau c'est dû à auxonne troll ça
veut dire qu'il ya dedans
s'ils ont regardé à la loupe au lieu de
voir des molécules d'eau on verrait des
molécules de 1,23 il n'y a pas d'eau
dedans c'est que du hall 3 et quand vous
l'ouvrez ça y est ça sent le sous bois
servant extraordinaire ra moi je suis
fana de champignons et dans la forêt de
rambouillet il y en a plein et mais à un
moment il dans la saison il y en a plus
et ça tombe bien parce que il reste ça
toute l'année
alors celui là par exemple l'idée foot
grain ça veut dire qualité alimentaire
et les mêmes cacher et donc je me suis
dis bah tiens sur m de m'accuser alors
il faut en prendre une goutte qu'on
dilue dans un vide
vie on prend une goutte de la discussion
qu'on met dans un litre d'autres vies on
prend une goutte qu'on met dans un plat
pour 10 personnes
c'est très très très très concentré et
jean-jacques salle une odeur
extraordinaire donc voilà en vie deux
fois de suite n'allait d'eau-de-vie way
à peu près alors du coup enfin en gros
c'est ça dans une piscine quoi et alors
ce jour là donc je fais et puis je me
dis il y en avait un autre alors bah
tiens ici par exemple il ya de la bbc de
la vanilline de 565 alors j'avais
celui-là que je mettais dans mes autres
vie j'avais suivi que je m'étais aurait
plat et je me suis dit tiens c'est
marrant on pourrait faire la cuisine
rien qu'avec ça tire peu plus de viande
peu de légumes plus de fruits plus de
poissons vie de pignons oui parce que
c'est possible alors je dis pas qu'ils
vont le faire je dis que c'est possible
mais que c'est comme quand la musique
électro acoustique est né dans les
années 50 c'est dire qu'il ya des gens
qui ont vu qu'on est pas on n'avait pas
forcément besoin d'un violon d'un piano
ils ont pris un ordinateur ils ont fait
la musique
et aujourd'hui vous écouter la radio il
ya que de la seule du synthétiseur
initial donc voilà ici vous n'avez les
objets pour faire une cuisine
entièrement nouvelle qui pue de la
cuisine moléculaire s'appelle la cuisine
note à note s'est dévoyé penser ce qui
est une menace
oui penser penser à piano j'ai un canoë
je joue note par note c'est dire je
décide de faire les notes que je veux
sur mon piano
les parfumeurs parle d'orgue à l'esitpa
à versailles et à l'orgue des parfumeurs
bas ici on a là on à l'orgue du
cuisinier ou le piano du cuisinier si
vous voulez et l'idée c'est de faire les
consistances des couleurs des saveurs
des odeurs et c'est pas du rhin oui
parce que voyez vous un terme maintenant
deux mois votre histoire de champignons
nous octroie d'accord mais vous mettez
sur dans quel sur quel support comment
soit vous le voulez ajouter dans le
manche dans le temps je le mettais dans
mon fantôme et la nuit je crée je
voulais jouer à saint louis il vous
plait alors on va vous voyez ici par
exemple j'ai deux l'ovalbumine écart
levac des mines
c'est une poudre blanche au fait blanc
jaunâtre oui j'ai un jeu clair des
jeunes gens une adresse internet qui ne
paieraient pas n est pas périmé dans
vingt ans dans dix ans les gars alors
donc vous savez que dans un blanc d'oeuf
il y en a après 10%
non je les femmes et le respect de l'eau
donc ici j'ai mis 10 points 10 % de
cette poudre et de l'eau c'est
exactement comme du blanc d'oeuf en kz1
c'est l'équivalent la journée sauf que
ça ça casse pas alors que les yeux ça
casse bon je vois pas je vois pas
tellement l'intérêt pour supporter des
oeufs quand on a 10 tonnes
un camion de 10 tonnes qui sillonnent
les routes des yvelines et qui
transporte des oeufs ils transportent de
la flotte
c'est quelqu'un raisonnable mais ce
qu'au niveau nutritifs c'est aussi bon
qu'avant la santé de manger sain qu'une
protéine sur les mêmes bases
bonjour voila je voudrais c'est
l'équivalent d'un blanc mais pour
l'instant c'est un blanc d'oeuf ses cols
blancs d'oeuf là même leur dette alors
ici je vais vous prendre de ce qu'on
appelle des triglycérides triglycérides
penser à de l'huile je pense à du bras
vous versez ce les triglycérides
goutte-à-goutte vois je souhaite vous
voyez que les matières les matériels
sont pas très très moderne
ça va très bien donc pour l'instant je
mets les plus frileux aucun goût dans
des lots a eu lieu à bordeaux et les
protéines qui n'ont pas de goût donc on
est en train de faire quelque chose sans
goût d'accord mais on va le faire pour
la consistance parfait c'est bien la
voilà encore un peu ah oui il ya des
faits de jeu voilà mousseuse et
s'apprend oui oui ça prend comme une
espèce de mayonnaise mais son goût pour
l'instant il n'y a pas de boom
alors on va pas en rajouter 3 y est on
pour en faire plus
non notre adolescence à l'honneur
maintenant je voulais la couleur je veux
bien un peu de couleurs alors la couleur
que je joue prend au hasard j'en ai
plusieurs jeux ici j'ai des polyphénols
de ces deux jus de raisin de cépages
syrah d'accord donc ça ça n'est utile
que pas leurs couleurs non non non ça ça
en plus c'est la couleur et du goût mais
si on regarde bien celui-là il est joli
parce que vous voyez là alors c'est du
bêta carotène cartonne bêta c'est à dire
c'est le big board des carottes
j'en ai un peu on va tous y est ça va
paraître très longtemps et ça va devenir
orange comme une pure 40
si vous vouliez bleus je voulais être à
double s'il voulait lui faire je me dis
voilà là ça commence à prendre une belle
couleur
non non non parce que j'ai passé me tue
moi je sais pas cuisiner
j'oubliais ce genre de ce genre de truc
m'ennuie quelqu'un dans la terre pour
vous voilà vous êtes vous êtes bien vous
est propre à vous allez prends moi j'ai
donc je ne voudrais pas vous tâchez
voilà ça vient vite à ses ravisseurs
pour l'instant il ya une consistance pas
encore très ferme où on va l'améliorer
près une couleur alors papa nous faut
une saveur oui la saveur on connaît la
valeur vous mettez la peau de celles
déjà ça va donner une saveur âpre et
salé
si vous voulez du sucre pour faire un
dessert moi je voulais du vieux train
parce que le sucre ils allaient se
dissoudre dans l'eau puisque y avait de
l'eau
rappelait il y avait de l'eau avec des
problèmes l'eau du lot du faut bien
l'avouer donc maintenant se trouve cela
va être sucré sabayon c'est un truc
c'est après que john et sucrés qu'est ce
qui vous manque là dedans maintien les
cuisiniers professionnels
je ne suis pas savent toujours qu'il
faut mettre une toute petite goutte
d'état de m
ils appellent ça soit de cognac cru soit
de rome soit de 20 en fin de cuisson
donc l'âge et de l'éthanol alcool c'est
l'alcool d autres vies il est pur
blatche jean mersch 2 donc maintenant ça
va rehausser la saveur parce que la
saveur de l'éthanol c'est pas ça veut
pas ça n'est pas sucré principe pas mr
c'est encore quelque chose de bien
réussir ou non c'est une saveur
particulière c'est une saveur vous
voulez vous voulez quoi vous vous
laissez pas tiens mes champignons alors
à bon j'y suis et pourquoi vous
regretterez pas des champignons là l'âge
et du glucose moi j'aime beaucoup le
glucose les ducaux c'est pas du sucre
c'est un sucre mais parce que là vous
avez une claque du sucre déjà à faire
goûter le voir avec un double emploi
non c'est pas su creuser d'où elle met
d'accord c'est pas c'est une sensation
négocier et c'est bon je dois le savoir
ces noms vous mais demandez des
nutriments dont l'un n'a pas non non cci
bouyer moi je mets du glucose presque
tout mais aussi parce que c'est une
sensation en bouche qu'il est très très
gourmande d'accord qu'est ce que je
pourrais vous mettre à bastien vitamine
c au sort du lot on sort de l'hiver vous
avez besoin d'un peu de peps le web et
applaudit tamil c'est qu'est ce que je
vais vous avez compris oui maintenant
alors maintenant alors maintenant on va
faire un peu
on va continuer la consistance parce que
là on a commencé la consistance on va
pousser tout ça et on va le cuir parce
qu'on a le droit de cuir à l'oral que
red dans we remettre ça comme ça ici up
jolie jaune c'est ce que je vais vous
dire c'est très joli mais l'artiste
c'est ça alors on est artiste la peau
donc là je peux vrai voir s'il allait se
passer comme il ya de l'eau et que c'est
chaud c'est chauffé par le micro ondes
elle va se mettre à bouillir donc ça va
gonfler mais si ça gonfle ça veut dire
qui fait son degré comme il ya des
protéines de l'oeuf à 100° elle coagule
donc quand ça gonfle on dit ah bah tiens
ça doit être cuit dans mes gâteaux
recèle ça commence est ce que dans votre
livre là qui vient de sortir
ça y est adhérente ils attendent un
travail je vous répondrais une seconde
parce que acadie aqaba ou la non
nécessité un espèce de méduse de
matières jaunes sucre est un peu salée
chaude
si vous avez mis de la vanille de l'or
vous avez un vrai dessert alors ça ça
s'appelle un gypse le nom de ce plat qui
est une nouveau place à plein régime
donc ça ça me faire des terres des yeux
voilà à la vanille non à la vanilline
c'est pas comme vous c'est autre chose
on entre il faut pas refaire la cuisine
qui se fait déjà ça l'intérêt c'est
justement écouter un métis c'est
passionnant mais encore plein de choses
à dire
et puis ben écoute on a hâte d'aller est
ce que pierre gagnaire fait de la
cuisine autonome dans ses restaurants
alors le nouveau plan wahlen le chick
corea
les diables créé le mettre à la carte
l'instant aujourd'hui même il est à une
téléphone thaler il était à las vegas
donc mais il va revenir il va lille va
leur goûter mettre au point et caetera
et en général quand il l'a préparée il
le met toujours à la carte
donc d'accord mais il ya d'autres
quartiers alors qu'à d'autres
bah oui parce que il suffit qu'un et
s'il y en a un on avance des autres veut
comme il ya un chef par exemple
jean-pierre le peletier l'hôtel
renaissance vague à la défense qui sert
des granités note à note par exemple
d'accord il ya michael schubert qui est
un chef au renaissance bagram qui a mis
au point va commencer mais qui
recommande à sa commande d'accord et on
peut s'amuser soi même a atteint déjà
les produits dont vous parlez dans le
commerce c'est finalement je donne des
recettes dans mon livre de recettes qui
sont basiques
ces cinq là pas de problème
génial bon ben moi je vais aller
m'acheter de la petite fiole de
champignons et à gros merci
et puis sur moi bientôt pour une
troisième
bah oui je suis apte à se développer